assalamu alaikum brothers and sisters
this
is the norwegian parliament
a few days ago we arranged a rally
in front of the parliament and i was one
of the speakers there
the rally was addressing
the racist
islamophobic
anti-muslim group
saiyan stop the islamization of norway
who have been traveling around the
country
burning the quran
in front of our mosques for too long
we were demanding justice we were
demanding that these people be
prosecuted
that this racism ends now and
subhanallah brothers and sisters you
will not believe what happened
while we were there and i was
expressing how it makes us feel when
this racist individual comes to our
mosques and we are there with our
families to worship allah
and this racist individual comes with
police protection as well
and he starts calling muslims
rapists
saying that we are murderers
saying that we should be deported from
the country
that our mosques should be set down
that we should be put in concentration
camps yes he actually believes that and
he expresses that we should be put in
concentration camps
how does that make us feel
how does that make our small children
feel
and then he picks up the quran
as a symbol of eradicating islam and
muslims
he burns it
when i was addressing our concerns
in this regard
we see this military jeep come here
the quran banner is coming
with his friend
his friend comes out
and he burns the quran at the very
demonstration
where we are asking for justice and
prosecution against these very crimes
and when the brothers they try to stop
him and they extinguish the fire
they realize that
serious damage has been done to the
quran
so what does he do he takes out a new
quran puts it on fire
and throws it out of his car
brothers and sisters
this islamophobia has gone too far
it's gone too far
we cannot accept this anymore and that's
why we need to take action right now
brothers and sisters we are establishing
a da'wa center a masjid an islamic
institution
to establish the deen of allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala
to inform the society
that our religion is free
from his false accusations against islam
we are nothing near rapists we've got
nothing to do with murders
islam is a peaceful religion
so brothers and sisters we need your
help your urgent help
to help us establish this islamic
institution
and by doing so we are humiliating
this evil person
he thinks that he can extinguish the
light of allah
he thinks that he can
remove
the mosques
and the islamic presence
in this country by doing what he's doing
so we are making him the very reason
for the beauty of islam to prevail for
the message of the quran to reach the
hearts and minds of the norwegian
society
every time he bounds the quran
every time he insults muslims every time
he scares our children
we will raise money and we will raise
lots of money
and we will build our islamic
institutions we we'll build our mosques
we will build our taoist centers we will
give out quran we will inform the
society of what this deen really is
so he thinks that he can
fight or combat islam but in fact
whenever he does what he does
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is giving
victory to his deen through your hands
through your hands
so that's why my dear brother or sister
give
from your right hand
whatever you can
so much that even your left hand will
not know how much you gave
and expect the reward from allah
venerating his deen for defending the
honor
of your brothers and sisters and for
defending the honor of islam and the
book of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
click the link to donate now jazakum
foreign